me too the bunny guards the entrance to  the world's most valuable start up  inside show me's employees work  furiously at achieving the company's  sales target of 100 million smartphones  this year they've only managed about a  third of that so far but they're led by  a man with big goals shamis founder lei  Jun is often called the Steve Jobs of  China but he may be on his way to  becoming a cult legend in his own right  it took him just five years to catapult  his company to the number two spot on  the Chinese market right behind Apple  shall me success is based on two key  strategies it tells top quality tech at  low prices the operating system for its  phones is like Google's Android but with  Xiaomi products on it second it sells  its smartphones mostly online cutting  down on retail costs in the process  Xiaomi also relies heavily on popular  buzz created by word of mouth now that  buzz is making its way across the  Pacific shall me now aims to push into  the US market